Join the first,
a beautiful day and in quite some time.
Uh, today, uh,
we're very pleased to have William
Ryerson as our guest speaker and he is
president of the population media center,
which by the end of the of the lecture
period, you'll know what that is.
Uh,
he graduated from Amherst college
and then he became one of us.
He was a graduate student
at Yale studying Mars, Mars,
the entomology and the ecology
of, of insects. And that field,
people seem to realize that humans are
pushing even the insects out of existence.
So he then became interested in,
in the human aspects of
ecological and population kind of things.
33 years ago he started working in the
field of reproductive health and then if
I get 15 years and that he started,
uh,
being involved with a group that was
making TV programs and radio dramas in
developing countries and that are on
social issues of things that are troubling
the societies in which they're shown to.
And eventually he founded this group,
the population media center and is
both the founder and the president of,
of PMC.
And the soap operas are different than
the kind of soap operas that were used to
in America.
And their purpose is to explore the social
change and deal with the issues that
are of great currency for developing
countries where the culture is changing
rapidly in one direction or another,
or not changing rapidly
as as the case may be.
And one of the big four is
women's reproductive issues,
population issues, HIV
issues, child bride issues,
all of the kinds of issues.
A lot of the ones that we've
been talking about in the class.
What's nice about him and do
do is SEL training of course,
is that both in the design
of of of these programs,
he uses really good academic research.
What's really known about social change
and the induction of social change.
They just don't go off and be artsy
fartsy about it. Really study what,
what is the successful way of doing this?
And then not only that,
then there's really three stages of
professionals and one understanding the
academic stuff so you
know what you're doing.
Then getting the very best people in
whatever country you're working in.
The real good actors,
they're the major producers and you know,
groups that really know what they're
doing in terms of entertainment and that
leads to great success, which
you'll describe. And then further,
the third step is once you've done it,
did it work. And that's the real, real,
real serious research finding out
you've had, you've done something,
you're hoping to inculcate some sort
of social change. Well did it work?
And that's not easy,
but again,
Bill's group has used the most careful
and stringent academic research to try to
get at that issue.
And so these,
these programs have turned out to be
very popular successes and you will,
you'll hear about that.
And they have indeed been successful
in fostering social change.
And so I put bill into the category of
people who have made a difference and
this is not a huge category.
Uh, and so I'm very proud to,
to have to introduce him to you.
Bob. Thank you very much.
Pleasure to be with you. Um,
as Bob said, I started my career, uh,
here at Yale as a graduate
student in ecology and evolution.
And it was just 40 years ago,
last October that I sat in the audience
at the forestry school and heard Paul
Erlick talk about his then recently
published book, the population bomb.
Uh, he had been invited to give
that lecture by Charles Remington,
who founded this course and who was,
uh,
along with Paul and an attorney
from a Connecticut named,
uh,
whatever his name was, an
attorney from Connecticut. Uh,
along with Paul and Charlie Remington
founded zero population growth. Uh,
immediately after the lecture that
Paul gave and I had dinner with Paul at
Remington's house that night,
got very interested in Dick
Bowers was the attorney's name.
I know it would come to me sooner or
later when those synapses connected. Um,
I had dinner with a Erlick at
Remington's house that night,
uh,
took a huge interest in this issue,
which of course continues to this day.
We're growing by the equivalent
of a new Egypt every year,
uh, on a global level,
about 82 million net growth.
And the environmental impact
of that growth is immense.
So I began at that point to think
about how to address population issues,
how to try to bring about a slowing
of of population growth rates and um,
how to also ameliorate the
impact of humans on the planet.
MMM.
The conventional wisdom at the time
was set up family planning clinics,
which indeed was a good idea.
A lot of that happened particularly in
the 70s with strong financial support and
leadership from the u s government.
Something that changed
over the last few decades,
but ha is coming back into popularity,
uh,
with the new administration.
Um,
but indeed what became evident even in
the 70s was that the solution was not
just the medical model of setting
up family planning clinics.
Uh, indeed, um,
there was a need to get
people to use them. Uh,
there was great progress made,
particularly in the 70s in meeting
the already existing demand.
So we went from 10% of the world's couples
using modern methods of contraception
in 1962,
somewhere in the 40% percentile,
um,
in the late 1970s.
And then since then it has crept up
to 55% of adult couples using modern
methods. The 45% non users, however,
outnumber the 90% non users of
1960 because of population growth.
So,
uh,
we have as big a problem ahead of us as
we did in 1960 but we also have another
problem which is the reasons
that they give for non use.
Back in the early 1960s,
the primary reason was lack of
access to contraceptive methods.
Now in country after country has less
than 2% who give that as their reason.
And the number one reason
is wanting more children.
That is the bulk of the
nonusers of contraception.
When you take them out,
maybe 200 million, uh,
uh, couples, there is um,
another hundred million that are uh,
not using contraception but don't
want an additional pregnancy,
at least not in the next two years,
which is the standard question that's
asked in demographic and health surveys.
The top four reasons they
give for their non use,
our fear of side effects.
They've heard it's dangerous, uh,
male opposition,
religious opposition and fatalism.
Now a couple of stories about these
fear of side effects is something that
indeed has been intentionally planted
by some religious zealots who are
spreading rumors,
particularly around east Africa
that condoms contain the AIDS virus.
So people are actually dying
because of this misinformation.
They're afraid of using condoms.
They heard that they
contained the HIV virus,
and so they're having unprotected
sex and getting aids and dying.
It's really a criminal misinformation
campaign motivated by people who just
think artificial methods of contraception
or not a good idea for theological
reasons that most of their
victims don't understand. Um,
and for that matter, that I don't
understand, but I've tried. Uh,
male opposition is in part male
opposition and it's in part lack of
communication between husbands and wives.
So sometimes in traditional societies,
women think they're husbands are opposed,
but they've never had a conversation
about it and their married life because
this is something that they're
embarrassed to bring up. Fatalism,
uh, is the subject of a very
interesting paper by Etienne Vanderwall.
I'll you've read it.
Okay.
So you know about fatalism and belief
that whatever God has decided for you must
be fine without any idea that you have
the right in the ability to determine
the, your own outcomes of your family
life. And then religious opposition. I,
when I say this in the mass media,
I, all of a straw, a lot of fire,
but there is no religion that
as opposed to family planning,
uh,
you may have heard otherwise.
There are religions like the Catholic
Church and some conservative, uh,
mullahs in Islam who are opposed to
certain methods of family planning.
But there is no religion
that is preaching.
Everybody should have as many
children as possible. And indeed the,
the Catholic church is in favor of people
limiting their childbearing to those
they can afford to care for and love.
So the issue is what
methods are appropriate. Uh,
and certainly we know from Catholic
teachings that methods that are considered
artificial are not approved.
But indeed the church goes to great
lengths to teach what we used to call the
rhythm method,
periodic abstinence as a way of avoiding
unwanted or unplanned pregnancy.
Um,
in the world of Islam,
there are liberal thinkers
who are Islamic scholars,
like could to Booton Aziz of Pakistan
who have written that the Qur'an by
calling on women to breastfeed their
infants for at least two years is
inherently endorsing family planning. The
Korean doesn't mention family planning,
but,
uh,
by asking that women breastfeed their
infants for two years in low nutrition
societies,
this means woman must avoid pregnancy.
So there are in fact official findings
at all rom university to that,
to that effect.
And some Muslim countries are making huge
strides and adopting family planning,
leading one being Iran, which is now
down at replacement level fertility,
uh, in part driven by the ayatollah was
in that country who are promoting family
planning use. And in Pakistan now, uh,
the mosques are handing out contraception.
So there's a dramatic change
going on in the world of Islam.
Uh, having been in the population
field for a long time, uh,
I happened to,
uh,
go to the first world population
conference by the way,
I got involved with Erlick and Remington
and starting a Yale chapter of zero
population growth that no
longer exists. And, uh,
ended up on the National Executive
Committee of that organization,
but went to work with the population
institute in Washington and organization,
which I now also am president
of as of six months ago. Uh,
just to keep me from running
out of things to do. And um,
at this first world conference on
population held in Bucharest in 1974,
I took 65 students in 20 faculty members
from around the u s to cover this event
for newspapers across the u s each
of the students was accredited with a
particular newspaper and they all went
as reporters and they filed daily reports
and it literally generated hundreds of
news articles about this conference.
Um, Margaret mead happened
to be at this conference,
as did a colleague of mine from
the Institute, David Poindexter,
who now is the honorary chair
of population media center.
And the two of them looked at the
proposed plan of action at the UN had put
together and found that there was
no reference to the status of women.
So they sat down and wrote a paragraph
about the status of women and took it to
fill Claxton, who was the head of
the US delegation, uh, staff members,
the State Department under
secretary of General, I mean,
under secretary of state of the State
Department on Population Affairs and said,
Phil, the plan of actions has
nothing about the status of women.
So we've written a paragraph,
could you please introduce this in the
plenary session of the intergovernmental
meeting? And he said, well, this
is a meeting about family planning.
What's the status of
women got to do with it?
So by 1994,
the most recent UN conference,
which I also attended the world had come
to recognize that the status of women
is central to everything having
to do not only with population,
but with economic development
view educate daughters.
You Educate Flint families of the future.
Whereas if you educate a man,
you educate a man. So, uh,
there is a huge need to change the bias
among many people around the world that
their daughter's places in the kitchen
or for sale to some man in a polygamous
marriage and their sons places in school.
And so indeed promoting behavior
change in that area and,
and the human rights of women to play
an equal role with their husbands and
making decisions about family
life is critically important. Now.
Uh,
the first real interest I took in the
population field after hearing Eric's talk
about the ecological impact
of human encroachment on,
uh,
the wild lands of the planet and the
threat to biodiversity was the impact of
different age structures of human
populations on a economic welfare.
There's a Princeton
now deceased Princeton,
a demographer and the economist
named Ainslie Cole who has done,
did a lot of work in this area.
And I wrote a paper for my
paper at the forestry school,
um,
about his studies of the dependency
ratios that grow from different age
structures.
That is to say the number of nonworking
children per working adult and in very
large families, societies, I. E.
Rapid population growth countries.
Uh,
which are mostly low income.
People spend a very high percentage of
their income on immediate survival needs
of their children, food,
housing and clothing.
When they,
uh,
reduce family's eyes,
even without any change in family income,
there's money leftover and that money
can be spent on elective goods which
stimulate the manufacturing sector.
It can be invested in education,
it can be invested through the
government and infrastructure,
both of those build economic productivity
and most important it can be saved and
put into investments or just savings
accounts that builds capital,
that allows businesses to borrow
money and grow building employment.
And indeed it's the lack
of capital in many poor,
rapid population growth countries that
is keeping business from expanding.
And that as a result,
is leading to economic stagnation.
So when you look at the history of the
countries that have gone from developing
status to develop status
since World War Two,
South Korea, Japan, Hong
Kong, Singapore, Taiwan,
The Bahamas and Barbados,
each of those countries first instituted
strong voluntary family planning
programs.
And then their economies took off because
once the fertility rate got down below
about 2.3,
money was leftover capital was formed,
businesses expanded,
and some of the Asian tigers,
China being the lead among them now,
uh,
are undergoing rapid economic
growth for the same reason. Uh,
obviously economic policies and
various other factors affect this.
But demographics are a key
aspect of economic welfare.
Uh, infrastructure is
also, as I mentioned,
a key issue for economic productivity.
If you don't have roads to get
your crops or to market, uh,
you don't have airports.
Uh,
you don't have clean water and a lot of
other things that public infrastructure,
uh,
consists of number one
being education schools,
uh,
for the upcoming generations.
Then your economy's going to falter.
The average developing country spends
$13,000 for public infrastructure,
schools, roads, municipal
offices, water, sewer, Cetera,
electricity over the
lifetime of each person.
So per capita expenditure of $13,000,
but when you multiply $13,000,
times the net growth of the world's
population every year of 82 million,
what do you get?
Have you done that in your head already?
It's $1 trillion a year.
So the price tag just to keep
per capita infrastructure,
even in countries around the developing
world is that trillion dollars a year.
They are coming nowhere near making
this expenditure. They can't,
they don't have that kind of money in
part because of economic stagnation.
So that is being aggravated
by rural to urban migration.
Um,
and so you see urban centers in
developing countries where the urban
infrastructure is totally overwhelmed.
I was in Kinshasa year and a half ago and,
uh,
Democratic Republic of the Congo,
and that's a city that has infrastructure
designed to handle 600,000 people with
10 million people living
there. So in fact, thousands,
hundreds of thousands of people
who are sleeping on open ground,
they just have no place to sleep. Um,
the city floods every time it rains,
there's inadequate sewage
protection or sewage treatment and
the nuclear power plants that the Belgians
in their wisdom put in before they
left is sitting at the
edge of an erosion zone.
They don't have the money to stop it.
So the plant is in danger of falling
over and the environmental advisor to the
governor of Kinshasa
state who met my plane,
said he's been trying to,
uh,
he and the governor have been trying to
get the president of the country to shut
the nuclear power plant down
because if it falls over,
it's going to make the whole area,
including Brazzaville across the river
uninhabitable for thousands of years.
But the president won't shut it down
because he wants to get enough nuclear
biproduct to build a bomb so he can bond
and Rwanda because Rwanda has troops
operating in eastern Congo,
which I visited.
I was in Goma about a
little less than a year ago,
and I thought congested was bad until I
got to Goma Gomez where the fighting has
been going on recently in
North Kivu province. So,
um,
no,
when you see these extreme
examples of lack of infrastructure,
you realize this analysis by
Ainslie call was really prophetic.
So, um, now, uh,
the environmental impacts that Paul
Erlick talked about have gone way beyond
loss of,
of wild lands and threat to biodiversity.
In fact,
one of the biggest environmental threats
right now is pumping out water from
underground aquifers. Uh, 80%
of which is used for irrigation.
So, um, in China, in India,
in the American southwest
in every continent. Yeah,
that'd be great in every continent
on the planet.
Uh, because of our growing
population and the demand for food,
which you may have noticed
went up in price recently. Uh,
the farmers of the world are pumping
out the underground aquifers that rates
higher than the rate of
replacement by rainwater.
This is a classic example of
something that's not sustainable.
It's like taking money out of the bank
to pay for your daily living expenses.
You can only do that so long.
The water table in India is
dropping by 10 feet a year.
1,000 farmers of India a couple of
weeks ago, committed mass suicide.
They are having crop failures as they
can no longer drill deep enough to reach
the water. Um, and India
is green revolution,
which bought India maybe 30 years of
time according to Norman Borlaug who won
the Nobel prize for his
research on high yield,
wheat and rice. And by the way, who's
a member of our program advisory board.
Um, you know, the,
the green revolution crops are dependent
on high volumes of water for irrigation
and cheap oil, uh, not only to
run the tractors, but to make, uh,
pesticides and fertilizer, uh,
to keep these crops growing.
And in fact,
there's an article in the New York Times
within the last week about the coming
failure of the green revolution
crops of India, but every country,
or at least every continent is facing
this problem. Thank you very much.
Um,
the,
um,
Yellow River in China does not reach
the ocean two thirds of the year because
it's all being used for irrigation.
Uh,
and what is keeping the rivers of India
and China flowing periodically as the
melting of the Himalayan glaciers,
uh,
that has occurred seasonally
and waters those lands. However,
with climate change, we're losing
the glaciers and when they disappear,
which will be in the century at the rate
things are going and probably in the
next three decades,
uh,
that combined with inability to find
any more underground water will lead to
dramatic crises with regard to food in,
in Asia and for that matter,
uh,
the same thing is happening in Africa
and we're losing farmland in the American
southwest with the same process going on.
So this is a crisis in the making of
global proportions combined with climate
change,
which is causing the
rainfall patterns to change.
And in some cases rainfall to decrease.
So climate change is indeed the very
visible example of why our current pattern
is unsustainable.
We are already above 350 parts per million
in the atmosphere of carbon dioxide.
That means even if we stop driving cars
and stop heating with oil tomorrow and
we burn no more fossil fuels of any kind,
we are already going to have
devastating climate change.
But the arguments going on
in the halls of Congress are,
can we reduce the rate of
increase or can we maybe be,
can become so efficient that we level
off or slightly decrease our rates of
greenhouse gas output.
But this is like arguing over which
deck chairs to sit in on the titanic.
And unless we actually stop producing
greenhouse gases and find technology to
withdraw carbon dioxide and
methane from the atmosphere,
the climate is going over a cliff.
The century now don't slit your wrists.
Uh,
there are things we can do.
We have the technology to solve
a lot of these problems. Uh,
and indeed the population
issue is a clear cut example.
Population by the way,
is the climate issue.
How many children you have is
a climate related decision.
Because if as an American,
which Americans have the highest
per capita output of greenhouse gas,
you have two children,
each of whom consume 10% less than you do,
you're still creating,
uh,
an impact on the environment.
If you have three children,
you and your partner spouse,
uh,
are more than replacing yourselves and
you're having a potentially devastating
impact. On the environment. If a lot
of people make the same decisions.
So decisions on reducing family size in
developed countries in particular are
the least expensive intervention we can
make to reduce impact on the climate.
Even in the developing world
where population growth
is occurring the fastest,
the rather optimistic median projection
of the United Nations between now and
2050 is the addition
of 2.5 billion people.
That's eight times the U s population.
But at the rates of greenhouse
gas output on a per capital level,
it's the carbon equivalent of adding
to United States to the planet.
So if we don't solve
the population problem,
we're not going to solve
the climate crisis either.
So there are a whole bunch
of things facing us now.
How do we address all of
these behavioral things,
including the behavior of Americans will
clearly the mass media is influential.
Is there anybody here who
has never watched television?
No. Now when I grew up,
we did not have a television.
They existed,
but my parents thought they were a bad
idea. Uh, and they may have been right.
I don't know. But, uh, we went over
to our friends house and watch TV.
But indeed we listened to radio programs.
And in many of the developing worlds,
uh, uh, countries,
people still spend their evenings
listening to the radio because they can't
afford TVs in Ethiopia.
Only 4% of the population
can afford a television.
But radio is listened to by a
vast majority of the population.
So in our programs,
we use primarily radio,
although this methodology that I'm going
to tell you about came out of the world
of television.
Uh,
these are the countries in which we've
been working. We do long running,
serialized dramas,
sometimes referred to as soap operas in
which characters evolve into role models
for the audience, for elevation of
women's status, daughter education,
use of family planning,
small family norms.
We're looking at the idea of applying
this strategy in the United States to
address climate issues, uh, and
teenage pregnancy issues. Uh,
we also do talk shows,
we produce print materials,
but it is the entertainment serialized
dramas that are on prime time in these
countries where we have the largest
audiences and therefore have the biggest
potential for impact.
Uh,
the creator of this methodology is a
Mexican producer named Miguel Sabido who,
uh, was vice president of the
biggest commercial network in Mexico,
Televisa until his retirement in 1998
in 1975 after looking at the social
learning theory of Stanford
psychologist Albert Bandura,
who's still is looking at how role models
influenced behavior psychologically,
uh, still teaching at Stanford, uh,
and is probably the world's best known
psychologist and mode is the most
frequently cited psychologists and
professional journal articles of those who
are living.
Um,
he went up to actually interview Bandura
and went back to Mexico to create a
program to promote adult education.
And he realized from his
work in overseeing the
audience research division of
the network that his programs,
we're having a huge impact on audience
members, so why not use them for good.
And He created a soap
opera with three subplots,
one of which had illiterate
characters in it,
and the other two just were pure
entertainment with changes of fortune and
cliffhangers at the end of each episode
and all the stuff that goes along with a
soap opera. And they were on at prime
time, or this program was on a primetime,
it was called Venkat Amigo.
And it pulled in 33% of
the nation's viewers. The,
you know, melodramas defined as
the battle of good versus evil.
So the evil characters were telling the
illiterate characters that they were too
old or too stupid to learn and they should
forget about that and stick with what
they have.
The positive characters are saying
there's a whole infrastructure for adult
education. You ought to give it a try
and you can master it. You're not stupid.
And one by one,
these illiterate characters decided to
go to classes and sign up and take the
courses and get their diplomas.
And when they did,
so their lives improved.
And this huge audience witnessed this.
And Sabido then became
intentional in promoting this.
And he ran an epilogue in which he gave
addresses of registration sites for
adult education.
And this epilogue followed the episode
in which is most popular character,
God,
his diploma and it,
I don't speak Spanish and I broke down
in tears what I watched this episode
because it's so emotional.
This man crying,
holding his diploma because finally he
can read all the letters he's gotten over
the years from his granddaughter.
And then there's this epilogue perhaps
you two would like to do with this man
has done. And Sabido warned the
Ministry of Public Education. He said,
you may be aware of the show I'm
doing on Televisa. And they said, yes,
we like it very much. It's reinforcing
our public service announcements.
And he said, well, uh,
I may generate a crowd because I'm
going to run an advertisement after an
upcoming episode in which I give
addresses of your registration sites.
Can you handle a crowd? And they
said, oh, no problem. You know,
last year before your program started,
we signed up 99,000 people.
So we're set up to handle large numbers.
So he ran that episode and the
following day, in a single day,
250,000 people came in to try to register
and he continued to run epilogues,
uh, for the remaining weeks
of that 260 episode program.
And by the time it was done,
840,000 people had signed
up for adult education.
Then he did a program called our companyi
may come with me that promoted family
planning as a solution to a
problem of family harmony,
which is a perfect subject
for a melodrama. Um,
a couple arguing over how many children
to have and how to stay out of poverty
and so on.
And they ultimately adopt a method of
family planning and the live happily ever
after.
Similar impact on family planning use.
And it was during that
program that David Poindexter,
my colleague at Population Institute
discovered Sabido doing this program,
1976.
Okay.
And he did two things.
He convinced Emilio scargo who owned
Televisa to have Sabido do four more
telenovelas dealing with teenage
pregnancy prevention and family planning
promotion.
And he took Sabido to meet
Indira Gandhi in India. Uh,
I had been in India in 1975 when she
imposed involuntary sterilization,
um,
around the country and it caused the
family planning efforts in India to
collapse. And she lost the next
election that as she should have a,
it was a total mess and she
was very concerned about
India's population problem,
but she didn't try the right strategy.
And ultimately she got reelected
and before her assassination,
Sabido was sitting in front of her saying,
you don't need to use coercion.
You can role model this,
show people the benefits and they'll
decide for themselves whether to do it.
And so they ended up
okay
being sent to the head of the
Indian television authority
and Sabido trained the
writer minority.
I am Joshi who did India's
first homegrown soap opera,
which had a huge impact.
It's a subject of a book called
India Information Revolution.
It pulled in between 65 and 90%.
I'm anybody who had access to TV.
It generated 400,000 letters from viewers
to the Indian television authority.
Half of them address the
characters by name, uh,
with advice on who they
should marry and so on.
But a lot of testimonials on how the
program was impacted in the audience
members.
Okay.
So I got very interested in this
strategy and got involved in studying the
second Indian soap opera,
which had huge effects on it's 230
million viewers with regard to attitudes
about age of marriage, women
and acceptability of women
in the outside the home.
So one of the reasons this strategy has
been so effective where it's been tried
around the world is the long
running nature of the program. Um,
because you can't get somebody from say
the status of women of a woman in Sudan
to Gloria Steinem was a 62nd public
service announcement or with a one hour
drama.
You really need time to
bring about meaningful change
without creating backlash.
And by having gradual evolution of the
transitional characters and only in
response to situations that the
audience understands and themselves are
experiencing.
Can you bring about meaningful change?
And the emotional content of melodrama
is also very important for helping people
remember what they learned
from the programs as well
as remembering the program
itself.
Okay.
Do you remember what you were doing
on the morning of September 11th, 2001
and do you remember as clearly what you
were doing on the morning of September
10th?
Now what psychologists tell us is that
emotional involvement enhances memory.
So if you're a highly involved emotionally
in an emotionally based melodrama and
you learn lessons from it,
you remember those the rest of your life.
But if it's intellectual,
blah, blah, blah,
it may last not much
longer than the final exam.
And I'm probably guilty of that myself.
Ah,
there are several other theories that
Sabido incorporated into a theoretical
framework, both psychological
and communication theories, uh,
for the creation of this methodology.
And I'm not going to take the
time now to talk about them,
but they're very interesting and I
recommend you download this free book from
our website that has those theories
spelled out as well as examples of the
strategy as it's been
applied around the world.
She came to class last time,
she did red savvy, who is now
working for population media center.
And
so he's flying to Nairobi today,
um,
in Tanzania in 1993. Um, I took,
Everett Rogers was then associate dean
of the Annenberg School of communications
at University of Southern California
and a research design scientists for
Minneapolis named Peter Vaughan
to help design an experimental
evaluation to measure the effects
of a Sabido style radio. Surreal.
It was the second one done in Africa.
Um,
and it was broadcast with this pattern.
You can see the transmitting towers,
the dots and the shaded areas around
them or where you could hear the signal.
But we intentionally chose early prime
time when the tower in the Doma was
broadcasting locally produced music
with no social or health content.
So twice a week for two years,
a 208 episode program, uh,
people in the shaded areas heard 20,
not Wakati,
let's go with the times or let's
be modern qual in the control area.
They heard music among the characters
in this program was a negative character
named [inaudible].
He was an alcoholic truck driver with
a girlfriend that every truck stop in a
subservient wife named two
new waiting at home. Uh,
and he was in Tanzania in society,
every man's ideal.
This guy was a sexual athlete. He
was having a wonderful time. Uh,
he had girlfriends everywhere, you know,
draping over him at every truck stop.
Uh,
and so it attracted a huge mail following
more men than women in this audience,
but overall 58% of the
adult population listening
much to him,
Quad Jews surprised.
He found he was married to a
transitional character and to new,
uh, perhaps having read some
of the thousands of letters
addressed to her coming
into radio Tanzania advising her
that her husband was cheating on her,
stood up to him when he was home on
one of his visits and told them she had
heard about the aids epidemic and she
knew what he was up to on the road and he
was going to have to use condoms.
And she made that happen.
She eventually took a job and ultimately
she founded her own business and became
a role model for female
entrepreneurship in Tanzania.
Now if you're a script writer,
you probably figured out am quad to
become sick and for some time the audience
doesn't know what has affected him,
but they find out he now has
aids and two new throws them out,
but have ultimately takes him back and
cares for him in a separate bedroom until
he dies.
And the audience learned a
few lessons out of this. Uh,
we did nationwide random sample
surveys of 2,750 people annually,
starting with a baseline just before going
on the air and then repeated annually
for four years. [inaudible] 93 94, 95, 96,
97 and from 93 to 95,
this was the pattern of broadcasting.
From 95 to 97 we broadcast
the program and the Doma,
so we were able to measure and
broadcast areas and non-broadcast areas.
What was going on with regard
to self reported knowledge,
attitudes and behavior.
I also got the Ministry of Health to ask
new family planning adopters why they'd
come to the clinics.
Now in the survey at the end of year to
58% of the adult population listening,
82% of the listeners said the program
had caused them to change their behavior
to avoid HIV infection.
We were astounded by how
high an impact it was.
The most common change people said they
had made was reduction in the number of
sexual partners.
We didn't have the budget to hire enough
private detectives to verify those
claims,
but we got the condom distribution data
from the national aids control program
broken down by district and then the
districts that made up the control area
where they got all the national programs
about aids except for the soap opera.
There was a 16% increase
in condom distribution.
While in the broadcast areas there was
a 153% increase in condom distribution.
Now when we took all of the reported
behavior changes across the country and
extrapolated it to wherever
you could hear this program,
the cost per person who changed behavior
to avoid HIV infection was 8 cents us
on family planning,
we saw a 10 percentage point increase in
the number of family planning adopters
in the initial broadcast areas and zero
change in the control area around the
dome a transmitter.
When we broadcast the program in
Dodoma the following two years,
we had a 16 percentage point increase
in family planning adoption and in both
areas at the time of the broadcasts
were on the air and those areas,
41% of the new adopters named the
program as their reason for coming in.
The next most impactful intervention
was named by 11% so four to one ratio of
effects between this soap opera and
the next most impactful intervention.
Now.
It was right after seeing this data that
I started population media center and I
took rose Haji who produced the
Tanzanian program, Tom Kazoo,
who was the first African
trained by Sabido and the
first radio person to use it
and Sabido himself to Ethiopia.
And we trained a team of
writers to produce two programs.
One in I'm heart,
the national language,
which was 257 episodes long and the
second 140 episodes in Oromiffa.
The second most common language,
and those were on the air
for two and a half years,
starting in June of o to the [inaudible]
program was listened to by 47% of men,
45% of women.
The OROMIFFA program pulled in
another 25% of the population.
So we had well over 40 million
people listening to this program and
it became the subject of
daily conversations as well
as thousands of letters,
15,000 poured into our
office and Adis Abba.
But during the time these
programs were on the air,
most of them in response to
the arm Hark language program,
which had a better time slot.
One of those letters from was
from a woman who said, uh,
she was so happy we had addressed the
issue of marriage by abduction because you
may not know this,
but in rural Ethiopia,
the status of women is so low that it's
considered socially acceptable for a man
to grab a girl off the street.
And I mean a school girl take her home
and rape her and then she's considered to
be his wife and she stuck with her
abductor for the rest of her life.
So,
and parents won't take the daughter's
back because they're damaged goods and it
would bring shame on the family. So they
leave the girls with these abductors.
Now this is starting to change in courts
are starting to allow these women to
escape.
Uh,
we dealt with this in this very popular
program in this letter said thank you so
much for dealing with the
issue of marriage by abduction
through your character.
Wu Baalam,
our own daughter was abducted on our
way to school at age 14 and ended up
married as a result.
And we've been afraid to send our 12
year old girls to school for fear of the
same thing.
What happened to them when your program
played and dealt with this issue?
The entire village which had listened to,
it came together and we agreed to enforce
the law against bearish by abduction
and it's now safe to send our
12 year old girls to school.
So this is the kind of qualitative
information we got from those letters.
We also had listening groups that filled
out diaries after each episode and
periodic focus group discussions for
feedback to the writers and monitoring
through 14,400 exit interviews
at reproductive health
clinics to ask people why
they had come and baseline and post
broadcast quantitative survey across the
country
at the 48 clinics where those 14,000 exit
interviews were carried out at 63% of
the new reproductive health clients were
listening to the program or one of the
programs.
And over a fourth of the new clients
cited one of the programs as the primary
motivator for seeking services.
Okay.
Radio Ethiopia is 100% public
service broadcasting. Uh,
and a lot of programs dealing with AIDS
and family planning of all the people
who named Radio Ethiopia
or other radio programs,
96% named one of our programs,
4% named any of the other programs on
the radio as their source of motivation.
This shows increase in use of family
planning from baseline to non listeners to
listeners.
The increase among the listeners was
more than double the increase among non
listeners and highly statistically
significant and some of the non listeners
were clearly motivated through
conversations with listeners. Oh,
this is a decrease in not knowing
how to determine one's HIV status
and this is actual reporting of going
for HIV testing. Male listeners,
sod HIV tests at four times
the rate of non listeners,
female listeners sought tests at
three times the rate of non listeners.
Now we've done similar work
in these countries, uh,
in Vietnam.
We're currently on the air with a program
dealing with HIV AIDS on the voice of
Vietnam in west Africa. We did a
program dealing with child slavery.
The,
it was actually something that was
brought about through a request by Ben and
Jerry's.
And funding from them to get started.
And then funding from the u s government.
And we measured a quintupling of awareness
among listeners of the problem of
child trafficking and child slavery and
a doubling of interventions by listeners
to stop the practice.
Uh,
we've just gone on the air and Molly
with a program promoting family planning.
Uh, we've done two
programs in Nigeria. Uh,
first one was at the request of the
Rotarian Action Group on Population and
development that was setting up a surgery
to offer repair for women who have
upstack obstetric fistula.
Something that results from the daughter's
in northern Nigeria being married off
at age nine and getting pregnant at
age 12 and trying to deliver with an
immature pelvis and having obstructed
labor and ending up somewhat torn to
shreds and incontinent.
Uh,
these girls married the older men in
polygamous marriages generally then get
thrown out on the street
and live as beggars.
And the rotary clubs of northern Nigeria
set up a surgical center to repair them
because for $300, he's women can
be returned to a normal life,
but they know if they are unrepaired,
they're incontinent and they live on
the streets and they smell bad and their
social pariahs. So, uh, and in fact,
there are 800,000 women in
Nigeria with unrepaired fistulas.
So we were able to measure by promoting
family planning and delaying marriage
and childbearing to adulthood.
A third of the women coming to family
planning clinics named our program as
their reason for coming in.
54% of the women coming for
surgical repair named the
program as the reason they
were at the Ho at the clinic.
Uh,
the second program that on the air
currently as being named by 67% of family
planning adopters as their motivation
for seeking services in Rwanda,
currently 57% of family planning clients
and 59% of HIV testing clients name our
program as their motivation
for coming to the clinic.
We're also using the program to promote
preservation of mountain gorilla habitat
and more generally,
uh,
wilderness areas in Rwanda.
In Sudan,
the program addressed the issue of,
uh, of uh, female genital mutilation,
uh,
opposition to FGM and Sudan.
At the time that program was on the air,
went from 28% to 65%.
By the end of the program in Asia,
we dealt with a child trafficking also
and in Senegal we've just gone on the air
with the two programs in
two different languages.
In the U S we're working
with the Hollywood community
and partnership was the
Academy of Television, arts and sciences
and the screenwriter's guild of America.
We've done two briefings for
members of the screenwriter's guild,
the most recent one on climate,
population health and security issues.
We held in Hollywood and November.
And the one before that,
a bout a year and a half ago at
Emory school of Public Health,
uh,
looking at the role of entertainment,
television and addressing
public health issues.
And these are countries in which
we are developing projects.
I was in Papa New Guinea and Uganda in
the development of new projects in the
last two months.
But we have projects in various stages of
development in each of these countries.
Now how are we on time?
So why don't I take just a few minutes
and show you if I can make this work.
A clip from a documentary done by a
CNN vice president for environment,
no longer with CNN,
but she was head of environment for
CNN and Turner Broadcasting Woman named
Barbara Pile.
Um,
who did a documentary on this idea
of social content soap operas,
uh, in the Philippines
where it's a seal. Alvarez,
uh,
produced a program.
I'm not sure if I'm going to be able to
put this on full screen, but let's see.
Well,
I don't know what I'm doing wrong.
Let me do this.
I'll reject it.
Hmm.
Yup.
You sure can.
It's right in here.
Okay.
So this is a dock,
a documentary about this Philippine
program introduced by Jane Fonda and then
the documentaries by Barbara pile
of the storyline is about, uh,
two sisters, one of whom we
lopes, I think the age of 16.
And has a baby every year trying to
please their husband who wants a son and
it's a tragedy.
Okay.
So what do I do?
Uh,
I think you've done it.
Numbers,
people,
personal journey around the world.
Yep.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
well let's fix that.
Are there lights?
Oh thank you.
That's a half hour documentary but you
saw the part about it that is on that
a soap opera.
Um,
and I guess with that I thank you for
your attention and I'd be happy to take
questions.
Okay.
Are there any questions or comments?
Get cell phone once a week
and, well, some are daily,
some daytime.
How is it,
is that standard
at various all over the place and Latin
America its daily day time man primetime
in many countries it's twice a week.
Some are once a week,
but once a week is really not adequate
because you have to hold the audience's
interest for a whole week waiting for
the resolution of the latest cliffhanger.
So we like to do a minimum of twice a
week and some of them are three times a
week.
Yes.
Having a program
like, but halfway through
the show. How do you
well, yeah, look, okay, thanks.
The question was how do we deal with
people who are drawn into the program
halfway through a two year
or soap opera? Um, and the,
the answer is one of the beauties about
having several hundred episodes is you
can have a lot of discussion of what's
going on in the past by the characters.
So people who join the
audience partway through, uh,
the two or three years that are,
might be on the air,
learn a lot about it and they also may
learn about it from other members of the
community. Um, particularly in countries
where we have very high listenership,
like northern Nigeria,
our most recent measure was 82% of the
adult population are listening every
week. So, uh, they're, you know,
it's become a cultural event.
Uh,
so people who are joining it here,
both about the program from their
neighbors as well as hearing characters
talking about the past and getting
caught up that way. One of the,
one of the questions I'm often asked,
and maybe I should wait until
somebody asks me this question,
is how do we decide what it
is we're promoting? And, and,
and in a sense,
what gives us as an American organization
the right to go into some country and
tell them how to live. Uh, and indeed,
one of the things that we've adopted as
a strategy is looking at the policies of
each country.
Most countries are signatories with the
Cairo program of Action on Population
and development and of the Beijing
Platform of action on women's rights.
So if there are a signatory
of those documents,
then part of their national policy
is incorporated in those documents,
which are really global agreements
on the rights and status of women and
reproductive health.
So we use that as a starting point as
the basis for the values will be promoted
by the program.
And then the policies of the
country may add nuances to that.
So when we go into a country,
explained to them,
we are there to help them
promote their policies.
We're not trying to impose
something from the outside.
Yes.
How do you find that position from
governments or other institutions?
Uh, hardly any. Uh,
the question was do we have
opposition from governments? Uh,
one of the things about this strategy
is because we're working to support the
government's policies,
they are very enthusiastic about it.
And second,
we get very little opposition from
the public because of the very gradual
evolution of the characters.
And because by doing our homework and
really understanding the culture before we
ever get started and having
writers from that culture,
all of our programs are written,
produced and managed by country nationals.
We know what the taboos are
and we steer clear of those.
So we're not there to
give people shock therapy.
We're there to start where they are
and move in the direction of a better
reproductive health and women's rights.
But we don't do it in a way that
creates backlash or opposition.
Yes,
they were
made.
Um,
and the,
the question is with American
shows like seventh heaven, are we,
what's the comparison between
narrow strategy for promoting, uh,
not drinking and driving or abstinence
with the kinds of programs we're doing?
And the answer is there is some comparison
that is producers and writers of
American Hollywood shows are members of
society and their parents and they're
very aware of some of the problems and
sometimes they attempt to address issues
in the context of their program.
Um,
we had Neil bear as a speaker at an
event we did at Hofstra University, uh,
about a month ago, uh, who produces, um,
law and order and,
uh,
w also was a producer of er,
and they're very intentional efforts to
use some of these programs to promote
positive goals.
They tend to do so in one or a few
episodes as opposed to having a program
that's designed around a set of issues.
So it tends to be briefer
mentions of these issues. Uh,
and sometimes they're done well
and sometimes they're not. Uh,
but indeed there are lots of examples of,
of entertainment chosen
Hollywood, like, um,
the bold and the beautiful addressing
aids through a character named Tony who
finds out he's HIV positive.
Uh,
and they got a 800 number from Donna
Shalala when she was secretary of Health
and human services that they could run
after those key episodes for people to
call for information that show
generated more calls to that 800 number,
then 60 minutes treatment of HIV AIDS and
60 minutes has a much bigger audience,
but it was the emotional impact of
days of our lives that generated a huge
response by the audience. So some
of these have been very useful, um,
interventions, but they're quite
different in terms of methodology. Yes.
Followup studies
like accepted of contraception.
There is some evidence,
um,
of course you're asking a
fundraising question. Uh,
it is hard to get grants for
say, a 10 year study. Um,
but there are,
there is some evidence,
for example with Sabido is family
planning programs. They stopped,
uh,
addressing family planning issues that
Televisa unrelated to the controversy or
not of the content.
They stopped doing social
content broadcasting at
Televisa in 1985 and the birth
rate had come down dramatically.
It was the most dramatic decline in birth
rates of any developing country in the
20th century. During the 10 years.
Sabido is five family planning,
soap operas were on the air when they
stopped the birth rate plateaued,
but it did not go back up.
However,
our view is because there are new
generations coming along every year and
because people continue to need
information on a whole range of health and
social issues,
uh,
these programs should be seen
as a long term intervention.
We shouldn't say do a program for three
years and then walk away in the same way
that we wouldn't open a clinic for three
years and then close it down and hope
that the birth rate wouldn't go back up.
So we really see this as
a long term intervention.
But the evidence that we have,
probably not conclusive,
but it appears that these programs
lead to permanent change in norms.
Yes.
Yup.
Uh,
certainly in countries that have
a mature media market like India,
like Brazil,
uh,
we are adopting more a strategy of
working with the producers of existing
programs than trying to produce
our own and compete. So in Brazil,
for example,
we're working in partnership,
the Social Merchandising
Department of Tele of TV global,
which controls 65% of
the Brazilian audience.
And that strategy, actually
the, their department,
he emerged because of the partnership we
formed originally through a meeting, uh,
David Poindexter and I had with Roberto
Marino who own the network and it was
being done through the
product placement division,
but ultimately they set up a whole
division to promote social causes through
their telenovelas. And so we helped them
do that and we measured the effects.
For example,
36% of the women that planned parenthood
clinics in Brazil were there because of
one soap opera. We evaluated called, uh,
[inaudible] Davita pages of life. Um, and,
um, it's similar to what we're doing
in Hollywood. We're not, you know,
we may do a youtube soap opera,
but we're not likely to get
ourselves on the air on CBS.
So we're instead focusing on working
with writers of existing programs.
Yes.
I mean if they're,
if they're writing into the
characters and even suggesting
if that helps or hinders,
uh, it's, it's a question that, uh,
we try to understand before
we ever go on the air.
What are their attitudes,
perceptions of and consumption
of entertainment media.
Um,
and indeed the audiences in
terms of their sophistication,
their media savvy,
varied dramatically from a place
like Ethiopia to a place like India.
So there is no one generalization,
um,
but you know, there are many stories
about our experiences in Ethiopia.
For example,
the actress who played the positive
female role model for Corto in that first
program I was talking about,
um,
went into a vegetable market and women
recognized her voice from the radio show
and one of them said, you're for
Kirta. And she said, well, not really.
And they said, no, no, no. We
know you're for Kurt to, um,
well we recognize you from Yak
and cabinet. And one of them said,
I named my baby daughter after you and
hopes that she would be as wonderful as
you are. So clearly they're, you know,
they're not seeing the distinction
between fantasy and reality.
But on the other hand,
how many times have you heard this
about American audiences? So it's,
it's hard to know really.
Uh, but clearly, uh,
probably the lack of sophistication leads
to greater influence of the programs,
but it's hard to know.
Yeah.
One more question.
Applying this model to other social
issues such as environmental degradation,
because I mean really based on family
relationships and people's relate to each
other. And how do you
see, what's your nozzles,
what leaves the success rate of these
environment issues,
what other types of stuff?
The question is how do we
feel about applying this
strategy to other issues like
environment as opposed to family
life and family planning issues?
And the answer is we feel great about it.
However you point out,
it might not be the most exciting soap
opera to do a soap opera on recycling.
So it doesn't have the same sex appeal
or audience appeal as a program about
people's lives.
So we mix issues and we like to do
programs about life in the country,
in the eastern Caribbean.
The nine countries where
we're broadcasting a program.
That program is addressing both family
planning and preservation of the rain
forest of the eastern Caribbean in Rwanda.
Similarly,
um,
we're planning a program in Papa New
Guinea that we'll address conservation of
marine resources and family planning.
And clearly family life issues
are perfect subject for melodrama.
Uh,
you have to be very careful
how much conservation kind
of content you put into a
program.
But indeed you can have the life
of a village in a soap opera.
And for example,
in Papa New Guinea,
one of the fishing practices that there's
clearly a short term strategy is to
use dynamite to blow up the reef and it
stuns all the fish and they can scoop up
out of the ocean, but that's not
a sustainable livelihoods. So,
you know,
we can demonstrate that through a two
year or soap opera in a way that might
take many more years and be devastating
to the marine environment. Uh,
if it, if people just wait
until they're starving. So, but,
but the point is well taken.
It's,
it's something where we have to be careful
not to overload it with messages and
boring information.
It really has to remain an exciting
program or we'll lose our audience.
Well, I think we better call it quits
because we're past a adjournment time,
but I thank you all very much.
Okay.